estamos en la más grande protesta
indígena de la historia del país son 5
mil indígenas y un campamento
viniendo de 117 pueblos distintos a la
espera de la madre de los juicios
indígenas mañana el supremo tribunal
federal
decide la causa de los choques algo que
puedes describir el destino de muchos de
estos indígenas porque puede ser de
precedente para sus futuros los choc les
luchan para mantener la tierra que
consiguieran después de
1988 cuando fue promulgada la
constitución
de brasil se pueden seguir con sus
tierras eso significa que no van a tener
que retroceder 30 años en lo que es la
demarcación de tierras indígenas en el
brasil
pierden el agronegocio ya tienen los
ojos puestos en la expansión de la
frontera agrícola en el país los
indígenas esperan que no sea más un
revés de los tantos reveses de los
últimos años que han sufrido en el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro o muchos
incendios en las florestas de amazónicas
muchas invasiones por parte de minería y
otro y ganadería por ejemplo